et comme tous les mercredis on va parler
culture avec la chronique de johanna
soudry johanna bonsoir et ce soir on va
parler d'un chorégraphe jean claude
gallotta qui est tout prix ce mail en
cours et vous avez presque tout dit donc
il est cependant pas tout il est en
train de préparer un spectacle qui aura
lieu donc le samedi 6 octobre lors de la
nuit blanche de saint quentin en
yvelines
nous avons suivi ces ateliers qui sont
ouverts aux amateurs de 8 à 88 ans allez
on regarde marie laure était lent
courtoise elle avait participé l'année
dernière au projet de danse menée par
olivier dubois au prisme comblé par
cette expérience artistique marie laure
s'est inscrite au nouvel atelier du
chorégraphe jean claude gallotta
je trouve que c'est une occasion
extraordinaire de danser avec des gens
qu'on connaît pas forcément de tout
niveau qu'on soit simple danseurs ou
bien un peu plus expérimentés et ce lien
qui se crée entre nous et le plaisir de
danser est une expérience à partager une
expérience à partager entre plusieurs
générations
c'est le défi de jean claude gallotta
réunir et faire danser des amateurs de
tous âges pour la nuit blanche de saint
quentin en yvelines
les enfants plus de 50 enfants
après il donne la place à 50 adultes qui
refont un peu des gestes qu'on a un peu
vu avec eux et puis ensuite tous les
gens se déplacent ils vont sur
l'esplanade et là il voit la troisième
génération en fait des personnes âgées
qui refonde d'autres gestes et quand ces
personnes âgées ont terminé en fait
toutes les générations se retrouvent sur
l'esplanade et fonde une danse où il ya
150 danseurs en fait je trouvais ça
magnifique cette idée que tout le monde
peut être danseur et que tout le monde
peut danser de la maternelle jusqu'à la
tombe
le groupe des seniors répète depuis le
mois de juin avec yannick assistant de
jean claude gallotta
c'est une expérience assez touchante je
trouve de voir le mouvement traverser
les corps en fait qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de bouger et
puis voilà voir toutes les étapes du
travail aussi bien le début les corps
qui sont complètement fermés au
mouvement et qui au bout de trois
semaines de travail souvent complètement
25 personnes de 50 à 82 ans composent le
groupe numéro trois un groupe très
assidus et motivés
aujourd'hui justement on travaille sur
la précision on se rend compte qu'on a
interprété chacun des gestes à notre
façon avec notre style
il ya des fois on me dit que c'est bien
il ya des fois au contraire c'est pas
bien du tout il faut être très strictes
un cours de danse qui réserve bien des
surprises
une de nous et qui n'était de loin pas
la plus jeune qui a fait le grand écart
devant nos yeux ébahis
prochaine étape la rencontre avec les
autres groupes pour la suite des
répétitions avant le spectacle final
interprété au prisme à elancourt lors de
la nuit blanche de saint quentin en
yvelines
le samedi 16 octobre on va saluer simone
qui est l'auteur de ce fameux grand
écart elle est quand même âgé de plus de
80 c'est dommage on n'a pas vu non ce
qui a été très timides ont également de
leur faire devant la caméra mais là pas
vous dis-je donc en tout cas belle
prouesse eu sur sa red bull d'ailleurs
là c'est vraiment des gens qui soient
font partie d'associations de danse ont
vraiment des gens qui avaient juste
envie de danser avec un chorégraphe
professionnel tout à fait des gens
amateurs qui ont vu voilà les annoncé
qu'ils sont du maintien va s'inscrire à
participer cela dit beaucoup de
personnes ont déjà participé au projet
qui a été menée par olivier dubois l'an
passé toujours des jambes ou voilà qu'on
avait suivi c'était maxime le mène avec
une très bonne qui avait suivi donc ses
aventures sur plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois
donc les gens ont tellement aimé qu'ils
ont souhaité seraient inscrits cette
année avec jean claude gallotta donc
alors qu'au losc qui a commencé sa
carrière à grenoble oui c'est là bas qui
fonde sa compagnie de danse dans les
années 80 lors il devient rapidement le
directeur de la maison de la culture à
grenoble et c'est la première fois qu'un
chorégraphe est nommé à ce poste mais je
reviens à l'automne n'est pas que
chorégraphe il est aussi réalisateur
fait les multi casquettes monsieur et
réalisateur avec plusieurs longs
métrages et même écrivain puisqu'il
publie son premier ouvrage qui s'appelle
mémoire d'un dictaphone
après avoir quitté la maison de la
culture à grenoble sans suivre de
nouvelles créations davantage de
festival est toujours de bons retours de
la
res et il est où il ya aussi un lien
très fort avec le japon et notamment
avec le metteur en scène japonais padash
isuzu qui à la fin des années 90 mais
gallotta c'est aussi le ballet de
l'opéra de paris avec deux créations
présentées à l'opéra bastille en 1995 et
en 2006 dès 2002 il s'intéresse aux gens
et aux générations avec une création
pour le théâtre national de chaillot à
paris pour gallotta l'aspect humain est
primordial dans cet art je trouve que la
danse les formidable c'est que elle
permet justement une rencontre avec
l'autre on danse depuis toujours dans
les bals
on se rend compte et je voulais pas que
la danse contemporaine perdre 7 cette
force là et donc je travaille avec des
professionnels avec des générations et
avec des amateurs et ce qui est bien
c'est que ça crée un lien social aussi
entre les gens dans un lieu-dit trouve
que ça fait ça fait vraiment ce côté
familial qu'on perd de plus en plus
aujourd'hui plus en plus d'individus
elle trace en traçons les stressés et là
c'est justement pour regrouper les
gendres dans quelque chose qui est qui
et ludique mais aussi artistique
on apprend vraiment des choses danse
contemporaine qu'on adapte pour eux mais
c'est des choses profondes en fait pour
moi artistiquement
donc il ya deux de personnalités qui
vont m'aider de danseurs yannick hugues
ronde qui est dans la compagnie et
françoise balle goetz qui est une une
personne âgée en fait qui a commencé
très tard et que j'ai utilisée déjà dans
un spectacle pour montrer justement que
des personnes âgées pouvaient aussi
danser on voit là on aura vraiment de
direction comme ça pour m'aider à fonder
ce projet formidable autour du prisme
tafer par très bien de ce projet part
notamment du lien social qui se crée
entre les gens c'est un chorégraphe très
humain parfois certains sont un peu
pédant j'ai envie de dire alors que
voilà gens fous de galles auteur qu'on a
rencontrés et très très accessible très
ouvert
cette affaire semble enfin dans le bon
sens du terme c'est à dire tu as fait
très accessible on sent vraiment qu'il
est motivé par ce lien humain dont il
parlait justement dans l'interview
alors il est connu aussi pour un
spectacle qui s'appelait l'homme à la
tête de chou oui ça vous évoque
forcément serge gainsbourg un spectacle
créé en 2009 par gallotta avec des
paroles et des musiques gainsbarre et
interpréter enregistré pour l'occasion
par un attachement voilà donc c'est
vraiment un chorégraphe multi facettes
avec voilà et donc ça n'a retiré le la
restitution ses tanks à découvrir le 6
octobre à l'occasion de la de la nuit
blanche on dira salue notamment simone
assez que vous connaissez apparemment
pas non mais vous m'avez parlé de simone
qui faisait le grand perdant oui je
pense que vous parlez d'une autre juste
a dit si bonnes puisqu'on n'a pas vu les
images de s'immoler on nous a promis
levante qu'un que simone à 80 ans donc
on y sera le 6 octobre pour filmer ça
attention à vous s'ils veulent aller on
va complètement on va changer d'univers
on va quitter l'univers de la danse pour
l'univers de la musique avec un coup de
coeur joie pour un groupe engagé oui à y
mettre et on s'en va à guyancourt donc
ont quitté l'anc au repos guyancourt
avec le groupe hk les saltimbanks ils se
produiront sur la scène de la batterie
le samedi 28 septembre
ils se considèrent comme des citoyens du
monde et lors de la présidentielle ils
ont soutenu jean luc mélenchon en
l'accompagnant sur plusieurs meetings
alors on garde tout un extrait de leur
titre phare on lâche rien
ltd
du fond de ma cité hlm jusque lanta
campagne profonde notre réalité la même
est partout la révolte gronde dans ce
monde on n'avait pas notre place on
n'avait pas la gueule de l'emploi
on n'est pas les dans un palace on
n'avait pas la cba papa sdf chômeurs
ouvriers paysans immigrés sans papiers
ils ont voulu nous diviser
disons arriver tant que c'était chacun
pour sa gueule leur système pouvait
prospérer
mais fallait bien qu'un jour on se
relaye les clés tête remettait à tomber
en lâchez rien lâcher
on lâche rien
on a seul
voilà pour le groupe donc hk et les
saltimbanques qui a d'ailleurs fait
appel à la chanteuse brésilienne fab
flavia coelho pardon qu'on nous avions
rencontré l'année dernière lors de son
passage à la batterie de liancourt
justin et on lâche rien à la batterie de
2 lui en cours on va finir le lien de
famille du cinéma est arrivé un
réalisateur bien de chez-nous connue et
reconnue dans le monde entier il s'agit
de michel gondry originaire de
versailles je suis sûr que vous savez
catherine oui oui oui parce qu'on a
préparé le nom mais vous saviez avant
donc michel si je veux dire que s'ils
allaient onu doit comme film eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind la science
des rêves soyez sympas rembobinez ou
encore plus récemment the green hornet
donc michel gondry revient au cinéma
cette semaine avec deux oui ndiaye qui
s'intéresse comme son nom indique au
rapport du groupe donc nous oui en
anglais et à l'individu jeu donc assez
bien d'avoir des journalistes billag
c'est un petit peu donc le processus de
l'évolution du au sein d'un collectif
voilà comment ce que une personne
identité évolue au sein d'un collectif
après se retrouvent qu'est ce que
raconte un peu le scénario alors le
pitch de la fin de l'année scolaire le
dernier jour de cours s'achève et les
élèves d'un lycée du bronx quittent leur
établissement pour monter dans le bus
qui les ramènent chez eux c'est leur
dernier trajet avant les vacances d'été
l'occasion d'aller à la rencontre de ce
groupe d'adolescents où chacun a son
histoire
metz
une gueule de poissons à québec
sma
ça c'est vrai cela m'en mets dont long
du ruisseau
voilà bien une chronique engagé ce soir
oui hk et michel gondry de versailles et
c'est assez engagé bourg il faut dire
qu'il est et il est connu aussi parce
qu'il a réalisé des clips d'une célèbre
chanteuse
oui bien tout citoyen engagé un peu
folklorique fait beaucoup beaucoup de
clips et notamment il a fait le clip
aussi de daft punk we are the world
je vois là je crois que c'est ça le
titre où on voit les automates des
momies qui dans sa crypte très connue
donc aussi tous les clips de la
chanteuse bjork comme on disait si tel
est votre avis sur le film alors alors
est ce que vous nous conseille d'aller
voir d'aller le voir ça donne envie un
battant mais ça donne envie
pas donc celui parce que pour pouvoir
non si si mais c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur film de gondry
je pense que les fans remarqueront le
style du réalisateur sa patte comme on
dit moi j'ai tout de suite aimé le début
qui a ses rites mais après j'ai eu peur
de m'ennuyer un petit peu et surtout que
ça nous fait tourner peut-être c'est le
fait d'être dans un huis clos
on est tous dans ce but si j'avais un
petit peu peur de dire bon finalement le
film n'évolue pas finalement sans s'en
rendre compte en tout cas - sans m'en
rendre compte je suis rentré dans
l'histoire et j'ai voyagé avec ses
jeunes ce qu'il faut dire c'est que ces
jeunes en fait sont pas des acteurs
professionnels
ce sont des jeunes que michel gondry a
rencontré il a fait un travail avec eux
pendant trois ans quand même c'est pas
rien les jeunes lui ont raconté mme tu
peux les histoires qui se passait dans
leur vie au lycée et au bout de ces
trois ans il a fait ce film et il a donc
pris ses jeunes pour jouer différents
rôles sont plus ou moins les l'histoire
en fait de leur vie quoi voilà en bref
un film qui ne décevra pas les fans de
gondry je pense de la vie de joie la
cendrée sur le film de michel gondry
merci johanna merci quand va rester dans
le domaine du cinéma puisque comme tous
les mercredis ce sont les sorties ciné
sont les avis des téléspectateurs ça se
passe dans un futur proche donc avec des
robots qui aide les personnes âgées ou
handicapées et cetera mais c'est traité
sur un mode assez humoristique et avec 1
personne qui a besoin de ce robot enfin
dont le fils lui amène ce robot qui en
fait est un ancien cambrioleur qui perd
un peu la mémoire mais pas tout le temps
c'était un très beau film que des
sentiments divers et qui pouvait
alterner entre la joie et la tristesse
s'emplissent c'est un patron plus ouais
un peu oui
ouais voilà on va c'était très
intéressant ça parler de l'enfance et
puis de de la nature au japon oui tout
ça en plus c'est un dessin animé
japonais c'est toujours très dix ans
instructif et beau